nuevamente miles y miles de personas
salieron a las calles del centro de
londres en especial en cercanías del
palacio de buckingham el que fuera la
residencia oficial de la reina isabel
pero nunca su casa favorita para
despedirla algunos llegaron incluso 24
horas antes a esa avenida roja larga
conocida como de molt que fue
fundamental hoy en el cortejo fúnebre
suntuoso en el que se escucharon himnos
o fúnebres de beethoven y de hecho pan y
que acompañaron a isabel segunda hasta
el palacio de westminster en donde en
este momento en el westminster hall
sigue en cámara ardiente donde miles y
miles de personas también le están
rindiendo tributos personales estas
personas han estado haciendo filas en la
lluvia y durante el día pero la fila es
la buena noticia está avanzando
rápidamente pero se prevé que las horas
de espera podrían ser hasta de 35 horas
para poder despedirse de la reina isabel
lo que se está haciendo es que cada
persona tiene muy poco tiempo para
rendir tributo personal para que así se
pueda permitir que más miembros del
público puedan asistir a cámara ambiente
donde la reina estará por cuatro días
hasta las seis y treinta de la mañana de
este lunes 19 de septiembre antes de ser
llevada a la abadía de westminster
cuando se realizará el funeral de estado
les cuento además que ese no es míster
hall es bien importante para la historia
británica aquí también se realizó el
velatorio del héroe de la segunda guerra
mundial winston churchill quien fue
curiosamente el primer primer ministro
de isabel segunda y la semana pasada
ella conoció a su 15 primer ministro que
fue lis atrás también éste westminster
hall está siendo monitoreado las 24
horas por soldados que sirven a la
familia real y obviamente hemos visto
expresiones de cariño de todo el público
lágrimas y sobre todo mensajes de
agradecimiento y esa será la constante
en estos días antes del funeral de
estado se espera que también en las
próximas horas en los próximos días
podamos ser la lista completa de quiénes
serán esos mandatarios líderes de estado
presidentes que asistirán al funeral de
estado de isabel segunda ya se sabe que
el presidente de eeuu joe biden y su
esposa jill serán unos de los invitados
especiales también el presidente de
francia los líderes del g-7 y por
supuesto una parte importante de este
funeral de estado será el público porque
el público tenía un papel importantísimo
para la reina isabel 2a